[Musica]
la differenza di molti miei colleghi che
fin da subito si innamorano di questo
lavoro
già da piccoli hanno il fuoco sacro per
la recitazione
io l'ho fatto a lungo contro voglia
la mia prima lezione di recitazione è
stata un trauma
mi sono trovato in pieno periodo scuole
medie in una stanza costretto a imitare
dei versi di animali di fronte a facce
semi sconosciute furlati ringhia a buy e
tutti
versi che non potevo borbottare di
nascosto seduto in un angolino mi dovevo
esporre
non mi andava per nulla mi sentivo
ovviamente senza essere in grado di
decifrarlo di verbalizzarlo ma mi
sentivo come come davanti a un plotone
di esecuzione con i fucili degli occhi
degli altri puntati su di me e pronti a
sparare il loro giudizio definitiva in
fa marmi per l'eternità
ero terrorizzato
pensavo di morire veramente
ma l'ho fatto
semplicemente perché non farlo e
scappare a quel punto avrebbe richiesto
un coraggio maggiore
leonardo quello che è scappato dalla
lezione di recitazione
non so dire perché ci sono state anche
una seconda una terza una centesima
lezione il terrore non se ne era andato
era era sempre lì ogni volta era era un
salto nel buio il buio soprattutto a
quell'età non mi piaceva per nulla
poi la prima volta che sono che sono
salito su un palcoscenico tipo questo
molto più piccolo con il pubblico sotto
come adesso molti di meno
prima di entrare in scena
mi si è bloccato il respiro
ma ci sono entrato in scena con una
volta perché scappare a quel punto
avrebbe richiesto un coraggio gigantesco
che non avevo
bene mentre continuavo a a domandarmi ma
perché lo faccio continuava a farlo
eppure evidentemente non mi piaceva il
calcio le ragazze quelle si che mi
piacevano quindi ce l'avevo un parametro
di riferimento
recitare invece mi faceva solo una
grande grandissima paura questo era
l'unico sentimento chiaro
allora perché lo facevo come sfida
per la gioia che prova un sopravvissuto
per il sollievo una volta che era finito
perché
è perché una volta finito il liceo fare
il giro d'italia a fare provini in tutte
queste accademia di recitazione
col cuore che smette di battermi ogni
volta che iniziò il mio monologo
perché trasferirsi a roma vent'anni e
farne una
desiderando tutti i giorni di
abbandonarla perché tutto troppo per me
mi fa troppa paura con che coraggio poi
affrontare i primi set cinematografici e
dire le prime battute col terrore di
dimenticarsi come finiscono quelle
battute perché perché fare tutto questo
per tanto tempo mi sono fatto questa
domanda
non ho trovato una risposta accettabile
la risposta che non fosse un alito di
parole vuote ma ma che venissero dal
cuore
allora un certo punto ho
cercato di cambiare prospettiva e ho
smesso di chiedermi ma ma perché lo
faccio anche se mi fa così paura
ha provato a chiedermi ma
ma perché mi fa così paura
era la domanda giusta
e col tempo ho trovato la risposta
mi fa paura
perché ne cura perché ci tengo tanto
tantissimo perché i sogni fanno paura
poi è chiaro che oppure di cose tipo i
serpenti o gli zombie che non che non
desidero minimamente ma
ma ecco ho capito che per me la paura
è un segnale
è una sorta di spia luminosa che che si
accende in quella stanza dei comandi con
cui tutti noi cerchiamo di di ordinare
di organizzare la nostra vita
se ho paura ho capito che devo rizzare
le antenne e non seguire il primo
impulso che che mi viene di scappare
lontano
nella savana a cui leoni sarà l'impulso
giusto ma ma in assenza di un pericolo
di
incolumità fisica ho capito che non lo
devo seguire quell'impulso perlomeno non
subito
perché ho capito che se ho paura
ci sono buone possibilità che sia
qualcosa che io voglio fare qualcosa che
desidero poi grazie ad esse sono cose
che che desidero è che non mi fanno
paura e non per questo le desidero meno
ma se c'è una cosa che che questo lavoro
mi ha insegnato sono tante ma se ce n'è
una che questo lavoro ha insegnato è che
è che la paura
non è
necessariamente una nemica
è un'alleata spaventata e spesso la voce
di di quell'ombra appunto che che ci
accompagna e che cerca di metterci in
guardia dai dai pericoli dalle delusioni
più grandi
se lo riconosco che che lei che parla
questa quest'ombra io la posso
posso ascoltare e posso cercare di
comprendere le sue ragioni
e poi riformarla in una compagna
preziosa che mi fa da guida quindi sì
per me la paura può essere una guida
piccolo esempio concreto
quando mi hanno
proposto di venire qui la mia prima
risposta interiore è stata scuserete la
volgarità della mia coscienza ma si
esprime così e non la censura è stato un
secco col cazzo
perché mi faceva paura tanta tantissima
e ci sono validissime ragioni per cui la
mia ombra mi voglia proteggere dai
pericoli di esperienze come questa e io
lo ascolto e scontro tutte le sue
ragioni
da
ma chi ti credi di essere per parlare in
pubblico a la stigmatizzazione delle
capacità intellettuali degli attori
sono così mi e non di altri sono i miei
pregiudizi le mie paure
poi grazie a dio ho una certa pure
l'ombra
gli argomenti rifinisce e io la
ringrazio
e poi cerco di capire se ancora una
volta
quest'ombra che parla attraverso la
paura non sta semplicemente cercando di
proteggermi da qualcosa che in realtà io
voglio fare
questo braga un po come come una mamma
spaventata per l'incolumità del figlio
si
ancora una volta devo rispondermi che
così lo voglio fare
e quindi la paura mi indica quello che
voglio
e se questa paura smette di farmi paura
io la posso trasformare in un motore in
una scintilla in adrenalina
poi per non concludere con qualcosa di
così di assoluto di astratto è perfetto
perché di perfetto c'è solo la morte la
vita imperfetta perché cambiamento e la
paura e motore del cambiamento
una piccola appendice di di umanità di
dio né stampa
io ho capito che la paura mi può fare da
guida sì certo
ma qualche volta semplicemente non mi va
e ci sta ci sta accetto di essere pigro
timoroso e rinuncio
rinuncio sì ci sta rinuncio e mi faccio
cullare da
da questa mamma paura che mi tiene al
riparo delle mie quattro mura della mia
zona di corpo mi faccio cullare da mamma
paura che mi tiene al riparo dal mondo
che cela fuori composto pericolosissimo
però ne sono cosciente che ho rinunciato
a ottenere qualcosa che volevo mentre
guardo fuori dalla finestra quello che
ho rinunciato ad ottenere
ma stavolta no non mi va
voglio stare comodo comodo assicuro
e sto comodo comodo al sicuro
finché la noia la frustrazione
i rimpianti non si fanno troppo grandi
per essere contenuti in questa
asfissiante tranquillità e allora spacco
queste quattro mura della mia zona di
confort e vada incontro alla vita anche
se fa paura proprio perché fa paura
grazie
[Musica]